Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
"Coğrafya kaderdir."
İbn-i Haldûn, 600 yıl önce söylemiş bunu.
Eğer zeytinyağı üretiyorsanız
coğrafya kaderdir
ama hikâyesi olan
bir zeytinyağı üretiyorsanız
coğrafya kader değildir.
Türkiye, zeytinyağını dünyanın en büyük
zeytinyağı üreticisi İtalya'ya satıyor.
Hikâyesi olmayan zeytinyağımızı,
İtalya'ya ham madde fiyatına,
yani çok ucuza satıyoruz.
Zeytinyağımız orada İtalyan
şişesine giriyor.
Şişenin hikâyesinde Vivaldi var,
Rönesans var, Leonardo Da Vinci var,
Galileo var, Bruno var
ve zeytinyağı orada
hikâyesini oluşturuyor.
Hikâye kazanıyor ve bizim üçe sattığımızı
İtalyan on beşe satıyor, markalaşıyor.
İtalya'daki zeytinyağı fiyatıyla
Türkiye'deki zeytinyağı fiyatı
arasındaki farka da marka diyoruz.
Eğer demir, fındık, zeytinyağı gibi
somut şeyler üretebiliyorsan sadece,
coğrafya kaderin oluyor,
İbn-i Haldûn haklı çıkıyor.
Demirin tonundan, pamuğun kilosundan,
kumaşın metrekaresinden ibaret oluyorsun
ve seyirci olarak izliyorsun.
Ama somut yerine
soyut olanı üretebiliyorsan
bu coğrafyanın sana
armağan ettiklerinin üzerine
yazılım, tasarım, akıl, fikir,
hayal, hikâye koyabiliyorsan
coğrafya kaderin olmuyor.
İbn-i Haldûn yanılmış oluyor.
Oyunu kuran oluyorsun
ve ham madde ekonomisinden,
inovasyon ekonomisine geçiyorsun
çünkü somutun sınırı var
ama soyutun sınırları ve duvarları yok.
Bir tarafta teknoloji ve bilim
üreten ülkeler var,
diğer tarafta başkalarının ürettiği
bilim ve teknolojiyi tüketenler
ve hurafe üretenler var.
Ezcümle, coğrafya
eğer istersen kader değildir.
Bunlar geri kalmışlığımızı,
beceriksizliğimizi örtmek için
sığındığımız bahanelerden biri sadece.
Vasatlık tuzağından paçamızı kurtarmamız
ve şark kurnazlığından vazgeçmemiz lazım.
Büyüme ve kalkınma arasındaki farkı
ve Türkiye nasıl kalkınırı
konuşmak için buradayım bugün.
Çok kısaca kendimden bahsedeyim.
Amerikan Merkez Bankası
FED'de önce ekonomist,
sonra araştırma direktörü
olarak çalıştım yıllarca.
Türkiye'ye döndükten sonra,
Avusturya bankası Erste Bank'ın
genel müdürlüğünü yaptım
ve Türkiye'de sıcak parası olan,
dünyanın finansal başkenti olarak
kabul ettiğimiz Londra'da,
yerleşik yatırım fonlarına
danışmanlık verdim uzunca bir süre.
Ama bunların hepsi bir kenara,
hayatı yanarak öğrenmiş insanlardan biri
olarak karşınızdayım ben bugün.
Büyüme ve kalkınma dedik
ama dürüst olmamız lazım.
Hem uyanmaya, hem de birbirimizi
uyandırmaya ihtiyacımız var.
Eleştireceğiz, gerçeklerle
ne kadar geç yüzleşirsek
o kadar ağır bedel öderiz.
Zamanında dünyanın yarısını
13 yılda fetheden Büyük İskender,
kendisini hiçbir kusuru konusunda
eleştirmeyen yardımcısına,
''Artık sana ihtiyacım yok!'' der.
Yardımcısı, ''Nasıl olur
hükümdarım?'' diye sorar.
Büyük İskender, ''Bunca zamandır benim
hiçbir hatama denk gelmediysen cahilsin,
yok denk gelip örtbas ettiysen
hainsin demektir!'' der.
Eleştireceğiz, haddin anlamı sınırdır.
Had, sınırı kabul edenler için vardır.
Aydının, şairin, sanatçının sınırı olmaz.
Aydın sorumluluğu büyük olan kişidir,
geri çekilemez.
Bunca baskı ortamında cüretkâr
ve kararlı olmak zorundadır.
Yoksa düzenin yandan çarklısı,
yaşayan ölülerden olursun
ve iklim değişir,
devrim değişir, gün değişir,
sana şarkılar söyleten kadın da değişir!
Aziz Nesin'in dediği gibi,
''Söylediklerimiz kadar
sustuklarımızdan da sorumluyuz.''
O yüzden bugün
olabildiğince net bir şekilde
Türkiye ekonomisi nasıl kalkınırın
detaylarını ve ana yapısını konuşacağız.
Öncelikle şuradan başlamak istiyorum,
şimdi Türkiye somut ekonomi,
soyut ekonomi tanımını yaptık
hani katma değeri konuştuk
ama bir önemli detaya vurgu yapmam lazım.
18. sıraya geriledik dünyada 2018 yılında.
Neye göre? Büyüklüğe göre.
Peki, 2000 yılında neredeydik?
17. sıra.
30 yıl önce neredeydik?
Yine aynı yerde, 1-2 sıra,
1-2 satır şaşar o kadar.
Gerisi koca bir gürültü.
Kişi başına gelirdeki artışla
böbürlenip durduk bunca yıldır,
2000 yılında kişi başına
4 bin küsur dolarla
orta gelirli bir ülkeydik,
dünyada 65. sıradaydık.
Bugün 18 koca yıl geçti,
9 bin küsur dolarla
hâlâ orta gelirli bir ülkeyiz.
Üstelik daha da fakirleştik,
65. sıradan 71. sıraya geriledik.
Ne büyüklükte, ne de kişi başına
gelirde bir arpa boyu yol alamadık
ve orta gelir tuzağından çıkamadık.
Meselelere, hadiselere büyüklük olarak
bakmak doğru bir yaklaşım değil zaten.
Hindistan bugün
dünyanın 4. büyük ekonomisi.
Endonezya 2050 yılında, bu hızla giderse
dünyanın 5. en büyük ekonomisi olacak.
Almanya'yı, Fransa'yı, İngiltere'yi
hepsini geride bırakmış olacak.
Şimdi ben soruyorum bu güzel salona.
Büyük oldukları için
yarın sabah Endonezya'da
ya da Hindistan'da uyanmak isteyen var mı?
Aile başına 5 çocuk,
10 çocuk, 15 çocuk yapıp
fakirler ve muhtaçlar ordusu yaratarak
gelirini şişiren ülkeler
en yaşanılır ülkeler olmuyor.
En büyük, en uzun, en fazla,
en derin gibi iddialar ve hedefler,
en iyiyi sunamayanların,
en iyiyi veremeyenlerin koca bir avuntusu.
Büyüklük kompleksinden kurtulmamız lazım.
İstanbul'un büyük köprüleri
var ama geçilemiyor.
İstanbul'un büyük yolları
var ama gidilemiyor.
Büyüme gövde genişlemesidir.
Kalkınma katma değer artışıdır.
Büyüme adet için çalışır,
kalkınma kalite için çalışır.
Büyüme fason üretir,
kalkınma marka üretir
ve büyüme sorgulamayan ve her
duyduğuna inanan kalabalıklar yaratır.
Kalkınma ise ayakları yere basmayacak
kadar büyük hayalleri olan
bireyler getirir.
Büyüme, kalkınma için yeterli değil
ama gerekli, olmazsa olmazı.
Gladwell'in -- okudunuz mu bilmiyorum --
"Outliers" isimli bir kitabı var.
Kitabın çevirisini yapan,
"Çizginin Dışındakiler" demiş.
Ben hadsizler diyorum.
O kitaptan muhteşem bir alıntı yapacağım.
"Ormandaki en uzun meşe,
en sert palamuttan yetiştiği için
en uzun meşe olmamıştır.
Çevresindeki toprak derin
ve zengin olduğu için de.
Fidanken hiçbir tavşan
kabuğunu kemirmediği için de.
Çevresindeki ağaçlar ona ulaşacak olan
güneş ışığını kesmediği için de
ve en önemlisi,
onu hiçbir oduncu zamanı gelmeden
vakitsizce kesmediği için de
ormanın en uzun meşesi olabilmiştir."
Büyüme önemli ama bunu
kalkınmaya taşıyabilmek için
son derece uygun bir ekosistem
ve zemin yaratmamız gerekiyor.
Ekonomileri, şirketleri ve kişileri
dört grupta toparlıyoruz,
dört grupta sınıflandırıyoruz.
Birinci grupta, herkesin yaptığı işi
herkes gibi yapanlar var.
Bu, coğrafyanızın size
sunduklarının üzerine
anlamlı bir katma değer
koymadan olduğu gibi satmaktır.
Türkiye burada çok iyi.
İkinci grupta herkesin yaptığı işi,
herkesten daha iyi yapanlar vardır.
Otomasyonla fabrikalarda
verimliliği arttırırsınız,
burada da fena değiliz.
Üçüncü grupta herkesin yaptığı işi
herkesten farklı yapanlar vardır.
Kahve satar görünür
ama sattığı deneyimdir.
Film satar görünür ama sattığı kültürdür,
burada yok gibiyiz
ve dördüncü grupta,
kimsenin yapamadığı işleri
yapanlar vardır.
Yapay zeka üreten
Silikon Vadisi'ni konuşuyoruz
veya eğitim sistemini 0-6 yaş grubunda
kodlama üzerine kurgulamış
Finlandiya'yı konuşuyoruz.
Bizim Silikon Vadimiz yok,
bizim avm'lerimiz var, biz burada yokuz.
Oysaki gitmemiz gereken yer burasıdır
ve kalkınma ancak böyle gelir.
Bugün 100 birim üretiyoruz,
o 100 birimi üretebilmek için
65 birim ithalat yapıyoruz.
O, bu güzel ülkemin sınırları içerisinde
35 birimi biz koyuyoruz,
işte o bizim milli değerimiz ve çok düşük.
O yüzden de ucuz iş gücüne dayalı
sektörlerde uzak doğuya,
sofistike üretim yapan
sektörlerde batıya bağımlıyız.
Arada kaldık, sıkıştık.
Çıkış var mı?
Elbette var.
Bir yumurta hayal edin,
yumurtayı dışarıdan bir güçle kırarsanız
yaşam son bulur, omlet olursun
ama aynı yumurtayı düşünün,
içeriden bir güçle kırarsanız
yaşam başlar.
İçten bir güçle kırmamız gerekiyor.
Düşük gelirli ülkeler grubundan orta
gelirli ülkeler grubuna gitmek kolaydır.
Biz geldik oraya,
kişi başına gelirde 2 bin dolardan
10 bin dolarlara bir dönem ulaştık.
Nasıl ulaştık?
Somutu sattık, coğrafyayı sattık,
hikâyesiz ürünü sattık,
düşük katma değeri sattık,
parayı betona gömdük.
Buraya gelen çok ülke var ama asıl mesele,
orta gelirli ülkeler grubundan, yüksek
gelirli ülkeler grubuna gidebilmektir.
10 bin dolardan 30 bin dolara
ekonominizi taşımanız gerekir.
İşte bunun için kurucu sermayeyi
nereye yatırdığınız çok önemlidir.
Amerika tarımla oluşturdu
kurucu sermayesini,
bilim sanat kültüre yatırdı
ve bugün dünyayı yönetiyor.
Biz, kurucu sermayemizi
turizmle, tarımla ve demirle oluşturduk
ama heba ettik.
Avm'lere gitti, betoncuya gitti,
sarı hafriyat kamyonlarına gitti
ve orta gelir tuzağında kaldık.
Ne lazım?
İnovasyon ekonomisi lazım.
Kültür ekonomisi lazım,
fikir ekonomisi lazım,
hayal ekonomisi lazım, soyut ekonomi lazım
ve bunları başarabilmek için
beş şeye ihtiyacımız var:
Bir, yaratıcı sınıf oluşturmalı
ve o yaratıcı sınıfı korumalıyız.
Neden mi?
Toplumların %2'si zeki
ve yeteneklilerden oluşur
ve o toplumun kaderini
o %2'ye nasıl davrandığınız belirler.
O sınıfa devlet başa dersiniz,
yıldızların efendisi olursunuz.
O sınıfı kuzgun leşe atarsınız,
bütün geleceğiniz
ve değerleriniz heba olur.
Nepos; Latince'de yeğen demek.
Nepotizm; yeğen, adam, akraba kayırmadır.
İlkelliğin göstergesidir,
liyakatın reddidir,
sadakatin kabulüdür.
Kalkınmaya doğru gitmek istiyorsak
işi cehlin elinden alıp
ehlinin eline vermemiz gerekir.
Sıra dışı insanlar lazım bize.
Toplumsal normları kabul etmeyen,
elalem ne der diye bakmayan,
kalıplara girmeyen,
yeri geldiğinde güce karşı
yeri geldiğinde halkına karşı,
yeri geldiğinde de kendine karşı
ters düşme hakkını kullanma
cesaretini gösterebilecek
o tuhaf yaratıcı sınıfa ihtiyacımız var.
Bizi aydınlığa taşıyacak olanlar,
vasatlık konforundan
çıkaracak olanlar da onlardır.
Aydınlanma cüretli insanların işidir.
İki, kadınlar.
2008-2009 krizi yüzyılın
en büyük finansal kriziydi.
Karl Marx'ın tabiriyle,
gölgesini satamadığı ağacı kesecek
kadar vahşileşmiş kapitalizmin
yerle yeksan olduğu günlerdi.
Taş üstünde taş,
gövde üstünde baş kalmamıştı
ve o dönem 2011 yılı,
artçı sarsıntıların yaşandığı bir gün
IMF, OECD, FED bütün
büyük kurumların toplandığı
bir araya geldiği bir toplantı yapılıyor.
Toplantının sonunda
mikrofonu ve kameraları
Christine Lagarde'a,
yani IMF'nin başkanına uzatıyorlar.
Herkes küresel krizden çıkışla ilgili
önlemler açıklamasını beklerken
Lagarde, "Bir odada çok fazla
testosteron olmamalıdır," diyor.
"Bir odada karar mercilerinde erkek
egemen zihniyet olmamalıdır," diyor.
Bugün yaşanan sosyal krizlerin,
toplumsal çürümüşlüğün arkasında
erkek egemen ev hayatı, iş hayatı
ve siyaset olduğunu iddia ediyor.
Bu iddia mesnetsiz değil.
Bugün bilim dünyası, bu iddianın
altını ziyadesiyle doldurabiliyor.
Peki ya biz neredeyiz kadınlar konusunda,
kadınların iş gücüne katılımı konusunda?
Dünyada 133. sıradayız.
Kadınlara doğurganlığı nedeniyle
kıymet biçiyoruz bu ülkede.
Hatta anneliği yüceleştiriyoruz sürekli ki
başka hürriyetleriyle birey olarak
meydana çıkmasınlar.
Refah için, kalkınma için herkesin
iş gücüne katılmasına ihtiyacımız var.
Evde oturmaya mahkum bıraktığımız
kadınlarla inovasyon ekonomisi yapamayız.
Sizce kadınlar, bu ülkedeki kadınlar
133. sırada olmayı hak ediyor mu?
Üç, uygun bir ekosistem
oluşturmamız lazım.
Beraber oluşturalım
mantığını, diyalektiğini.
Refah için sofistike üretim
yapabilmemiz lazım,
o sofistike üretimi ancak becerileri
yüksek insanlar yapar.
O insanlar ancak nitelikli bir
eğitim sisteminden çıkar.
Nitelikli eğitim sistemi ancak özgür
düşünce ortamında olur.
Özgür düşünce için
evrensel hukuk ve adalet,
yüksek standartlı demokrasi
ve demokrasinin onsuz olmazı
kuvvetler ayrılığı gerekir.
Aksi hâlde ırmaklarımızdan petrol aksa
topraklarımızdan altın fışkırsa
doğal gaz fışkırsa
eğer uygun ekosistemi oluşturmamışsak
kurala göre değil, duruma göre
adalet benimsenmişse
o ülkeden kalkınma çıkmaz.
Dört, bakış açısını değiştirmemiz lazım.
Yerli ve milli diyoruz.
Ben içi bu kadar boş bir slogan
görmedim hayatımda.
Bankalardaki mevduatımızın yarısı
dövizde ama yerli ve milli diyoruz.
Patates, domates
pazardaki fiyatı dövize endeksli
çünkü ilaç, gübre, mazot
tohum, hepsi ithal.
Yerli ve milli diyoruz,
üretimimizin üçte ikisi ithal.
böyle yerli ve milli olmaz.
Buna olsa olsa dışa bağımlılık denir
ve asıl beka meselemiz de budur.
Bakış açısı dedik ya,
başımıza kötü olarak gelen ne varsa
hep dış mihraklar diyoruz.
Dış mihraklar hep vardı, hep de olacak.
Amerika için Almanya dış mihrak,
Rusya dış mihrak.
9 yıl yaşadım Amerika'da,
hiç kimseye rastlamadım ki,
Rusya bizi kıskanıyor desin.
(Alkış)
İçi boş söylemlerle
uğraşmak yerine Amerika,
dünyada en fazla patenti üretiyor
ve Broadway'de tiyatro üretiyor,
Hollywood'da kültür üretiyor,
Silikon Vadisi'nde bilim üretiyor.
Şimdi, eğer yerli ve milli olmak
istiyorsak önce evrensel olacağız.
Önce kimsenin yapamadığı
şeyleri üreteceğiz,
kimsenin koyamadığı kadar
milli değer koyacağız
ancak öyle başarabiliriz.
Ve beş, eğitim sistemi.
Güney Kore ve Finlandiya,
bu iki ülkeyle aynı yerdeydik
tam 40 yıl önce.
Coğrafya olarak da benziyoruz;
onlarda da doğal gaz yok, bizde de.
Onlar koptu gitti.
Biz ise elimizde
okuduğunu anlamada, fende, matematikte
ilk 50'de olmayan bir karneyle kaldık.
Neden? Onlar eğitime, insana,
en iyiye yatırım yaptı.
Biz ise avm'lere, betona
ve en büyüğe yatırım yaptık
ve şimdi öğrendik ki;
büyük binalarla değil,
büyük insanlarla yükselir bir ülke.
(Alkış)